WAS A SIMPLE EJECTOR TEST.
THE RUSSIAN MISSILE NEVER
ENTERED SPACE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPENDING THE
HOLIDAY WEEKEND AT HIS RESORT IN
FLORIDA.
TRYING TO KEEP HIS
ADMINISTRATION LOOKING FORWARD,
MANY ARE FASCINATED AND HAUNTED
BY THE PASS.
PETER IS IN WEST PALM BEACH.
>> WE HEARD A RARE CONCESSION.
>> A CLINTON.
THE 2016 DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE WHO
WROTE LIVING HISTORY WISHES WE
COULD REWRITE SOME OF HER
COMMENTS ABOUT TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
SHE IS NOT SAYING SORRY AND SHE
IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
>> IN THE HEAT OF BATTLE AND
POLITICAL BACK AND FORTH, I HAVE
SAID THINGS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE BACK.
>> ABOUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
CLINTON IS DONE COMPLAINING
ABOUT HER FAILED CAMPAIGN.
NOW HE IS ACCUSING ANYONE ADVISE
OR TO LEAVE 2016 IN THE PAST OF
BEING SEXIST.
>> I WAS STRUCK HOW PEOPLE THAT
SAID TO ME MOSTLY PEOPLE IN THE
PRESS.
GO AWAY.
I HAD ONE OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WORKS FOR ME DO A BIT OF
RESEARCH.
THEY NEVER SAID THAT TO ANY MAN
WHO WAS NOT ELECTED.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS SCOFFING
AT CLINTON'S CLAIMS OF GENDER
BIAS.
>> SHE IS WRONG COMPARING
HERSELF TO MALE CANDIDATES.
THEY WERE MORE GRACIOUS.
>> A FAMOUS DEMOCRAT IS SET TO
HELP CANDIDATES CASH IN.
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA READY TO
COMPAIN FOR CLAIRE McCASKILL.
THE 44th IS GET READY FOR THE
MID-TERMS LIKE THE 45th.
TESTING OUT A NEW CAMPAIGN
SPEECH FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS SAY DON'T GIVE
HIM ANYMORE WINS.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS NOT
READY TO LOOK AHEAD.
2016 IS STILL THE FOCUS FOR
ROBERT MUELLER WHOSE COLLUSION
PROBE IS HONEING IN ON FORMER
CAMPAIGN AID RICK DEETS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE,
FBI FORCES EITHER TO HELP
CLINTON BEAT TRUMP ARE UNDER A
NEW MICROSCOPE WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS ANNOUNCING
INSTEAD OF A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
WE HAVE WILL THE U.S. ATTORNEY
FOR UTA PROBE FOR WRONGDOING.
>> IF HE DOES HIS JOB WELL,
PEOPLE WILL RELAX.
IF HE DOESN'T YOU WILL SEE A
WHOLE NEW DEMAND FOR A SECOND
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> DEMOCRATS TRYING TO DIP THEIR
TOES INTO THE 2020 CONTENTION.
THE 2016 LUXURY  -- ELECTION IS